letter A are these adjacent angles are
these ones adjacent angles are these
ones adjacent angles or are these ones
adjacent angles okay let's go through
them one by one first of all when we
talk about adjacent angles adjacent does
mean next to an everyday language right
adjacent means you know right next to
one another but specifically speaking
when you work with an angle okay an
angle is made up of two rays and a
vertex the vertex you can think of as
like the hinge of an angle but when two
angles are adjacent to one another what
it means is that not only do they share
that hinge that vertex but they also
share one of the Rays one of the sides
of the angle so adjacent angles really
should look something like this
so you letter D they're sharing that
vertex and they're sharing that side and
they're next to one another right so
let's look at the common mistakes so in
letter A it's true that these angles are
near one another sort of adjacent but
not in the strict sense of what we mean
when we talk about adjacent angles so
this is not these are not adjacent
okay letter B we're getting closer the
two angles share that vertex for that
hinge right but they're still not
adjacent sometimes people will confuse
like vertical angles like when you have
two straight lines the angles that are
across from each other with adjacent
angles these angles are congruent but
they're not adjacent they just share
that vertex and then here let us see
what we have is we have these two angles
here what they're sharing like the side
okay like the side of the angle okay but
they're not sharing that hinge that
vertex okay so this these are not
adjacent angles and again letter D would
be the best scenario here so they share
that vertex that hinge and they're
sharing one of the Rays the sides so
that's what you're looking for when you
talk about adjacent angles I hope this
helps you to understand this concept
better subscribe to the channel check
out some of my other videos on Mario's
math tutoring YouTube channel and I'll
see you in the future videos